hello everyone and welcome to the
mindscape podcast I'm your host Sean
Carroll and if you're anything like me
you have been frustrated at times in
your life with your inability to
remember things once you get to be a
certain age you're allowed to blame your
lack of memory on your advancing age but
I think that all of us at any age are
frustrated by the fact that we would
like to be able to remember things that
we have been through have experienced is
a famous fact in psychology that human
beings have terrible memories and they
can be overwritten and you can think
that false memories are very true and so
forth so nevertheless there are people
out there who are SuperDuper memorizers
right you may have heard of these memory
competitions that people have and this
technique called memory palaces where
you basically associate some incredibly
long complicated lists of information
with physical locations either real
physical locations you know in your
house or in your yard or whatever or
made-up physical locations you build a
palace in your mind and that's we kind
of have some reasoning as to why that's
true in the brain you know memories are
about associations between different
neurons and one of the strongest things
that the brain is able to do is locate
ourselves in space so associating
different facts or figures with
different locations in space is a great
way to remember them so today's guest is
Lynn Kelly who has a broader much more
interesting take on this idea and the
usefulness of memory palaces she's a
memorizer herself she's a multiple time
champion for the seniors division memory
competitions in Australia but Lynn has
had a very interesting career she got
her undergraduate degree in engineering
she had a lot of work on information
technology and education and teaching
and then decided that what she really
wanted to do was become a writer she got
her PhD from Latrobe University in
English as a nonfiction writer she's
written a bunch of books on popular
science and skepticism and things like
that
she became fascinated with how
prehistoric pre literary indigenous
societies were able to pass down
information so accurately even though
they couldn't write it down
so she began to relate this idea of
memory palaces and the great memorizers
that we know about to constructions that
were built by these cultures before they
were able to write sort of in between
when they were nomadic cultures
wandering around and didn't really need
to remember that much about the local
terrain and when they developed the
technology to imprint knowledge and keep
it for a long time so Lin has a theory
which is becoming discussed in
archeological anthropological circles
that monuments such as Stonehenge are
actually ancient memory palaces that the
tribal elders or professors as I would
like to call them would be able to
associate different pieces of crucial
knowledge about how to live you know the
laws of the society and so forth with
the different individual parts of
Stonehenge and other monuments and it's
not just a speculative idea that it's a
theory that makes predictions and you
know there's different aspects that she
says must be true and she's been able to
argue that these kinds of ancient memory
palaces are found everywhere across the
globe in all sorts of different cultures
so it's a fascinating topic that we
discussed both how you remember things
and what it teaches us about ancient
societies and then also what the
implications are for us here and now
Lin's most recent book is called memory
craft it's a how-to book is how you can
use these techniques to remember things
better she's previously written an
academic book on this subject called
knowledge and power in prehistoric
societies as well as a non-technical
popular book called the memory code and
it's a wonderful combination of ancient
history anthropology psychology
neuroscience and education right here
right now
so this is a fun one I hope you're going
to enjoy this podcast let's go
[Music]
Lynne Kelly thanks for being on the
mindscape podcast it's my pleasure to be
here I will mention something this is a
bit of an unusual sorry you're a bit of
unusual guest for me in some sense
because I had not heard of your work
previously and I heard of it first
through a commenter on the Internet
Adrian Morgan who both on Twitter and
reddit was very persistent and
suggesting that you'd be a great guest
for mindscape
and more than just suggesting your name
he actually made the case he had an
excellent pitch for why talking to you
would be a fun topic so I just wanted to
do a little shout out to him and thank
him for suggesting your name thank you
yeah and so I was since I didn't know
about you and since probably many
listeners also don't but that'll be
different after this a little bit of
background might be helpful I just I
just have to let people know that
according to your CV you got your
bachelor's degree in 1972 and your PhD
in 2013 correct and one's electrical
engineering I start an electrical
engineering I go through teaching and
computing and end up in arts and
humanities yeah no I just love you know
fun trajectories for people that are a
little bit different than anything else
if my math is correct that's a 41 year
gap and I presume you're not in graduate
school for 41 years
no I taught for about 40 years so I
taught senior physics and maths in
computing and read and wrote and did
lots of things so yeah it's a gradual
turret trajectory people think that it's
all disconnected that what's engineering
got to do with indigenous knowledge
systems and memory it all makes sense
and this book on spiders in the middle
it and another great passion of mine it
actually all makes sense to me it's all
about asking for logical explanations
for things
some people find irrational and
certainly a fear of spiders is
irrational and living in the Australian
bush okay right there I know it's
irrational but I still have it anyway I
don't
I overdid the Cure I adore the curry
just all my work does make sense to me
but other people says as Bitsey but it's
not well then yeah so it's it's good
that's a good segue because we want to
talk mostly about your work on memory
and the Anthropology of it and what it
says about ancient societies but you
know as I'm sure you recognize if all
you told someone was that we're gonna
talk about Stonehenge now ancient
cultures had a form of wisdom that we've
lost you know there's a certain new a
Jewish slant that comes to that so I
want to give you a chance to let people
know you've you've written an entire
book about the skeptical point of view
that we should have about paranormal
phenomena absolutely I am rigorous
scientist through and through hard core
I'm a foundation member of the
Australian skeptics and that's why I
keep asking these questions because if I
can't find a logical explanation
terrific I have to change my views and I
have had to change views over time and
that's what's fun when your thinking
gets knocked about and my thinking on
indigenous cultures got thoroughly
knocked about when I did the doctorate
but I always come at these things from a
there is probably a rational explanation
type logic first and then I'll question
otherwise and frankly the logical
explanation is always there it's always
the one yeah I was gonna say when it
comes to your work on ancient societies
it's the ear faming that you found
logical explanations these wonderful
artifacts that we found everywhere yeah
and it has to do with memory and you
also you know you're putting your money
where your mouth is there too you've
become a bit of a memory champion at the
applied level as well as a theoretical
level tell us about that yes I get my
hands dirty and everything I do so when
I did the skeptics guide I was doing
psychic readings and things just to try
and understand the mindset because I
don't believe that people are stupid I
believe that they're vulnerable
or trusting and trusting and gullible
frankly I don't know the difference so
when I came to these memory systems I
stumbled over the fact that indigenous
cultures in and I'll start with
Australian Aboriginal but also work with
Native American
these indigenous cultures are memorizing
vast amounts of practical information
everybody thinks in terms of that
they've got some kind of paranormal
ideas about gods and things and they
don't understand science it's absolute
bunk and so once I started realizing
when they know about animals we're not
just talking kangaroos and birds we're
talking invertebrates in hundreds so one
study on the Native American Navajo
shows that they can classify 700 in six
and very scientific type classification
with behavioral and habitats and all the
rest all stored in memory and that's
just insects and when I stumbled over
that given that my own memory is
naturally extremely weak my logics good
my memories poor mm-hmm I started asking
the question how the hell are they doing
this and that derailed my PhD topic
derailed the book I was supposed to be
writing and set me on a completely new
trajectory so what does it mean to be a
memory champion there are competitions
it's like a spelling bee I lost your
question there did my job putting these
methods in practice but I also entered
the Australian memory championships as a
senior I'm 67 now I think yes that's
about right and so in a memory
championship you memorize shuffle decks
of cards strings of numbers in decimal
but also binary one zero zero one which
is my favorite event which is really
weird
names and faces which is something in
practice I have a lot of trouble with so
I've developed rhythms for that and
lists of words and so on and you
memorize them under time pressure and
I've taken out the senior Australian
senior memory title twice now and I have
trouble with the stress that competition
goes over two days and I don't handle
the stress very well others seem to be
able to stay quite calm
it's slightly different the competition
by the end is done on stage and
eliminates down to people which would be
more stress than I'd ever handle okay so
the Australian Championships are not in
front of a crowd no and the world ones
aren't a that it's only America that
only America size add this extra level
of pressure that's what makes this is a
special country though right now so
before we get to the ancient societies
but I think will be our main focus here
but I think that probably many listeners
are aware that there is something called
techniques for memory for memorizing
either huge amounts of information or
very long texts or whatever they make
might even have heard of the idea of a
memory palace but sketch out like you
know what we should have in mind when
you say that you've developed these
techniques and so of other people to
memorise huge amounts of information
very quickly this is what's astounding
until I did it I could not believe that
I was capable of memorizing these vast
amounts of information so memory palace
is basically a set of locations that
you're very familiar with so the best to
start with is your house and in each
location you place a piece of
information and the brain the
neuroscience the brain and the research
on place cells and grid cells naturally
associates information with location so
for example I've got all the countries
of the world the 242 but that's
protectorates as well otherwise we lose
foot Enrico in places so you start the
front door so that's China because I did
a mid population order not alphabetical
because I know what letter they all
start with I want more information once
I start with China and I imagine at the
front door a Chinese meal being
delivered hot I happen to love Chinese
food yeah go ahead and the guys
delivering it in full Chinese outfit I
think the outfit I've got him in is from
about five or six hundred years ago but
let's not get too fussy and so that
image is very strong I move on to the
next location and I have India and there
I have a bookcase
and I look under the bookcase I've
actually laid down once to watch a full
bollywood production going on down there
now that's stupid action only done once
has got India in firmly and then I can
add all sorts of things third one is
America which is where I'm sitting right
now I have Donald Trump sitting opposite
me he permanently sits at a table in my
kitchen if this was a sad choice that
you made it used to be Barack Obama and
I wish you'd stayed there I won't get
into politics but it seems to change
when the presidency change you do that
so on so I have a location that's
associated now if I want to add so the
States of America I would create a story
or use other things like looking around
where I am now because I've got the
states around me and so these methods
work more much more powerfully than just
a mnemonic you know my very earnest man
just shear a snake shows nature's path
for the planets people have different
versions of it I can't add more
information to that but this location
I'm sitting at for America I've got a
tablecloth I've got the legs of the
table I can add endless amounts of
information so that's known as a memory
palace and the great Greek and Roman
orator Cicero Augustine back Tahoma all
use this method because you then imagine
yourself walking around your palace and
you will withdraw whatever information
you want it's unbelievably powerful it's
always been associated with the ancient
Greeks my PhD research showed that this
is exactly the same method is developed
by all indigenous cultures long before
the ancient Greeks our Australian
Aboriginal cultures then there's about
300 of them currently date back to
60,000 years ago and we have strong
evidence of these stories being stored
this way associated with the landscape
at least 10,000 years of landscape
changes at the end of the Ice Age it's
amazing research it's coming out of
America as well these stories are
unbelievably
robust and they're using analysis yeah
and so I guess I've learned something
just by reading some of your stuff
because this I'm sure was just my fault
but I always thought of memory palaces
as being metaphorical as being sort of
imaginary places that you built in your
mind and associated with things but
you're talking about using real physical
locations and all the different aspects
of them to help you memorize long lists
of things absolutely
some people can use them purely
virtually and create them in their mind
I can't I've tried I don't think my
imagination or ability to him image is
good enough for that but I learned first
from indigenous cultures from our
Aboriginal cultures before I knew about
the greco-roman memory palaces so I
actually came at it from using that
Aboriginal people will talk about
country and their on country country is
sacred to them and sacred shouldn't be
seen as purely religious and as younger
I I don't know if your audience all over
18 and they nun cry who's a well prairie
woman who helped me a lot with this
research said to me the elders were
pragmatical buggers and in our terms
buggers isn't it a term of endearment
but for stubborn so I'm not being rude
she said the elders are pragmatical
buggers we wouldn't have survived if
they weren't and she pushed me to look
at these knowledge these stories that
were told sounds superficial and
childlike that's because they are
because you don't get the detailed
stories until you're initiated and so
we're hearing what the children would
hear so you're grounding the information
in the physical landscape it's so much
more robust and then as you get
initiated you get layer upon layer of
complexity let's pause for a second to
talk about the great courses plus I know
that mindscape listeners don't need to
be told that there's no reason to stop
learning just because you've stopped
going to school and the great courses
plus is a wonderful way to do that it's
a streaming service that brings you some
of the best lecturers in
world talking about their areas of
expertise you have unlimited access when
you join the great courses plus two
thousands of lectures on topics from
radio astronomy science fiction as
philosophy the Ottoman Empire you can
learn a new language how to play chess
and so forth and with the great courses
app you can watch or listen just about
anywhere
I have several courses on the great
courses myself one of them is the higgs
boson and beyond it was a wonderful fun
introduction to this discovery we made
just a few years ago one of the biggest
findings in 21st century physics so we
have a special offer for mindscape
listeners you can get an entire month
for free and to do that you have to go
to the great courses plus.com
slash mindscape that's th e great
courses plus don't forget the plus.com
slash mindscape happy learning and how
much do we know about you mentioned
place in grid cells the neurobiology of
this one thing that's been interesting
to me over the course of the last year
as I've been doing the mindscape podcast
is several times in several different
ways we've been getting this message
that thinking and the action of our
conscious self cognition and so forth is
not just located in the brain it's not
just a computer sort of spread out
throughout our bodies in some way right
and but nevertheless there are different
neurons doing different things is the
phenomenon of a memory palace understood
from the neuroscientific point of view
or is that still a frontier it's still a
frontier in some ways but it's fairly
well understood and I'm working with
neuroscientist dr. Jennie Roger at
University of Western Australia and
she's looking here Oh science I'm
looking at the these memory pulses and
how they match and the neuroscience is
absolutely compelling that when we think
of some memory or think of some
knowledge we actually lay down a
physical neural pathway at that moment
every time it's extraordinary
but it won't hang around you need to
repeat that that thought and that
Association for it
build up and become robust and some
things become much more robust than
others music is one that stays very
robust so you'll see people with really
quite severe dementia that have not
responded to anything play familiar
music and they will respond that's right
deep in our memory systems through the
hippocampus and the long-term memory
place is the other one in the 2014 Nobel
Prize for medicine went to the
scientists who looked at the
relationship between place cells and
grid cells and so on and the way we
memorize so when we are so if we look at
this table and think America I'm doing
what's called in neuroscience a temporal
snapshot I am putting two things at the
same time and therefore they're
associated so you get a lot of parents
will say when did that happen all my
child was about six and work it out that
way it's because you've got a temporal
snapshot so instead of letting it happen
naturally using memory palaces you're
actually forcing your brain to do what
it does naturally and they're
reinforcing it it makes sense that our
brains would be very good at remembering
where we were in space and therefore
associating things with that I sometimes
wonder not in this context but it's
appearing to me now has the invention of
computers ruined our ability to figure
out how the brain works because the
computers that we build work in
different ways right in a computer the
ability to remember a file has nothing
to do with an association with some
other set of information but our brain
naturally does that it kind of makes
sense in retrospect oh I my poor brain
wants to go to directions at once this
moment firstly Socrates worried about
writing then long I hate to think money
would have thought of of Google but he
warned that writing and Plato wrote this
down because Socrates we have no written
records from Socrates but we have Plato
writing down his arguments and he argued
that if we relied on writing we would
stop using our memories and stop
learning how to do it and
that morning comes from way back then
but memory palaces were taught
obviously all indigenous cultures teach
these methods and it was taught in
classical times in Greece Medieval
Renaissance all taught formally and then
we dropped it now if you add technology
as well we are relying on secondary
memory storages all the time there's
another whole aspect to this if you use
Google or something and I love the
internet and Google don't get me wrong
but you are narrowing down to what you
already know to look up I didn't
understand till I use this how a memory
palace would change that so if you just
take I've got ten kilometers of memory
palaces in action now but it's in my
countries one which is one of my
shortest I've got all the countries now
as you walk around you start to ask
questions because I've got in population
order so China India America Indonesia
Brazil Pakistan Bangladesh Bangladesh is
coming in just with Russia before Japan
before Germany America not before
America before all the European
countries that have had so much impact
on our history and that we know so much
about if you compare Italy Italy's right
up the gut so instead of my brain starts
saying why do I know so little about
Bangladesh why with this massive
population has it had a massive impact
colonized other countries so you start
asking all those questions now it's a
much younger country in us it hasn't got
the resources that's been at war all the
time but I didn't know any of that it's
getting this big picture that has
started me doing that now if I listen to
the news and anything comes up about any
country like some much smaller country I
know about its population I can guess
its population approximate but I've got
a hook and so I'm suddenly interested in
all this stuff that would have just
passed over before and this is certainly
a lesson because I think that some
people are going to think
well memorizing long lists of things is
a parlor trick but one of your points is
that making all these associations is
really a form of knowledge not just you
know something that replaces a Wikipedia
page absolutely because you start seeing
patterns which the brain does naturally
but you've got a ground of information
so I've got all my countries in the
world I also walk through history I
start at four and a half thousand
million years ago I'm pointing now which
is now using you for what pointing at
the front wall which is the Hadean era
and you realize it took me about four
years of doing this before I realized I
should call that Hadrian's Wall which
there you go yeah you start making these
and some people are a bit quicker than
me I walk right around the block one way
and end up back here at a thousand BC
and then I walk the other block I've got
the doll time scaled out and get back
home at today well in 1900 then I go
round the garden and end up with today
so I have a location for every moment in
time and every place on earth and I hook
them on but things will get hooked into
more than one location and you start
messing around with it and then there's
all sorts of other methods
it all starts meshing and when people
think of these memory methods in terms
of just the competitions they have it
very neatly categorized but indigenous
cultures don't neatly categorize they
mesh everything together so your
landscape memory palace song lines
they're called an Australian pilgrimage
trails in America ceremonial roads in
the Pacific they are one form but then
you sing and dance and perform in
ceremony which is a knowledge
reinforcement reinforcing those neural
pathways which is why indigenous
ceremonies are so important to be
repeated and so lots of methods get
meshed together yeah I mean part of it
is the association with places but like
you're saying the song I presume that
other senses right you know touch and
scent and so forth might
associations we could take advantage of
when trying to remember things okay now
I'm going to bring out a prop this is
really really good way but you'll have
to describe it or I will this is what
you can describe what you see this is
actually a model of an African Luke
Casas from the Luba people of the Congo
there are none of the real things in
Australia but America has couple in
museums and I examined one at the
Brooklyn Museum in New York and this is
based on it but adapted for my knowledge
so what it is do you want me just to
describe oh well so you're holding up
something that is more or less the size
of a book and there's some backing
material that you've decorated so tell
us what the backing material is and what
the decorations mean okay the backing is
carved and that's tortoiseshell pattern
and the loop and people it's well
documented use that as a memory aid but
the front is carved with different
carvings and shells and beads are nailed
on and in the research I read that they
encoded to this little bit of hand held
wood they encoded a complete history
geography and essentially a knowledge
system an encyclopedia and I thought
well I'm a skeptic I don't believe I'm I
didn't know enough about it so I grabbed
a bit of wood now I'm holding up a
different bit of wood which is actually
a bit of wood from just a square bit a
rectangular bit from when they were
building our veranda which I'm now
pointing to which is again useless to
you and I just glued a whole lot of
shells and beads onto it to see if this
would work and I started coding a field
guide I've got upside down a field guide
to the Victorian bird that doesn't
matter for your image it does for me
describing it so I then started encoding
the 412 Birds native birds of my state
of Victoria so we have a block of wood
in front of us I'll show a picture of it
on the blog post for the podcast if
people want to see it and you've glued
you know it looks like something that
you would sell in a store as a souvenir
of you know the local colour but you're
saying that there's a KO
there and you there's an enormous amount
of knowledge encoded in those shells
glued on that piece of wood right I
start with the a neo at the top but I'll
go to the second bead what you won't be
able to see is that there's a little
tiny speck on it when I look at that
I can see a duck tail wagging so this
bead represents all the ducks and I
can't look at that not see the duck tail
wagging and there's a little nap next to
it another little speck which in my mind
is a net and now today are the Ducks
there's sixteen ducks to be memorized
now the first one is relates to a magpie
goose about the fifth is the Swan
Magpies and swans are two of our main
football teams so I have a story linking
them all of a football match that goes
wildly out of control so the
Australasian Shoveler is burying all the
dead the masked duck they saw straighten
but the must that's off in the bushes
using his musk scent for methods we
won't discuss the hard heads bashing
everyone up so I've got a story that
gives me all the ducks now I don't
believe that all it that the Shoveler
really buries dead but that story gives
me the list and then I could start
linking more and more on I could not
believe how effective this is and a lot
of people have tried it since reading my
books and are finding the same thing and
we're using this with kids of four and
five I know does this mean that you
choose which shell to glue on there
because you're gonna want it to
represent something specific or is it a
case where almost any noticeable thing
about the shell you could turn into an
association with what you want to
remember you can't that I just did this
randomly
I hadn't at that stage even decided what
I was going to encode to it when I did
it properly the second time with the one
that looks like the real lacasa
I did lay out this is a history of
writing from proto-writing right down to
contemporary scripts and that is laid
out that little thing there's an Inca
Kapoor a knotted cord device so that was
laid out and that may
an absolute blood but even if you stick
to something that has no patterns linked
with it it will still work very well
because your brain will make those links
so up here I dribbled the glue down the
side because I'm not really good at
crafts that happened to be where our
Lyrebird is and that's men you're a day
so that looks like a man's urinated down
the side of my porno
vulgarity violence will always work well
as memory devices the brain remembers
those things yes why mythology which are
actually encoding pragmatic knowledge
that's what a lot of my research is
about mythology has these wild
characters vivid stories lots of
violence of sex and vulgarity because
the brain unfortunately I have to admit
memorizes those things very well none of
this seems like it would be helpful in
memorizing a deck of cards with a bunch
of ones and zeros on it do you have to
be a little bit different when you're
doing these real-time competitions not
really the abstract objects like numbers
and cards have no action no meaning no
emotional response so what you do is you
give a character to each of the cards
okay so my ace of spades is Homer my toe
of spades is Pythagoras now Homer and
Pythagoras both wear togas so that
became a problem so I converted that
over to Homer Simpson so now I've got
Homer Simpson as my ace of spades my two
spades Pythagoras measuring out
triangles and things let's just take the
eight of diamonds is now a snowman for
me so if I get those three in a row I
will have Homer Simpson measuring a
snowman so I've now got an active image
and I place that in the first position
in a memory palace so when you're
memorizing a deck of cards
you've creating characters of story and
characters if I can get nothing across
more than this if you add character and
create character out of abstract objects
that makes them come to life and you can
then create memorable images and the
Greeks
clearly did this do we know that they
did this because they said that they did
this was a we have records of the Greece
explaining how to memorize I think
absolutely they wrote Cicero in
particular wrote quite a lot on memory
and as he's a time he was very famous
for iterating on memory
so yes grammatica was the character that
taught grammar and bashed you if you
didn't get your commerce right and
things except I don't think they use
commas spelling right and so on so yes
they created characters for all this and
those memory booklets and pamphlets that
have come down to us and we're used
right into the Renaissance the same
memory palace methods for using palaces
characters stories and so on so
absolutely
they didn't became handheld devices but
that's really just a miniature memory
palace right it works in my brain
exactly the same I don't take this with
me when we go birding and I I memorize
lists and so for example we see a
honeyeater we're not quite sure which
one it is honey eaters are our biggest
group of birds here there's 36 of them I
can reel off the 36 so we can do it my
process of elimination but I don't take
this with me I know it's so well that
it's with me in my mind all the time and
Cicero's techniques maybe fell out of
favor once printing and reading became
more widespread but once we had books to
download our knowledge onto once you've
really got printing and that they
stopped being used as much but in the
medieval times when books were very rare
they were used in all the time and books
were designed by this principle that's
why the medieval manuscripts which were
designed to be memorized have all the
fancy stuff around
they left space to add comments in all
the time to keep interacting with it to
add little drawings if you look at
Tibetan mandalas and Chinese narrative
Scrolls you've got a whole lot of ways
where the memories are put into images
now I can read a page of a book when I'm
studying and at the same time be working
out what I want for dinner and what I
want for dinner
stay there the page of the book is gone
I can write notes without engaging with
them because there might be words I
don't know
I cannot convert that into a story or a
picture or an attachment in the memory
pass without actually engaging with the
information because I have to shift the
mode the mode of information so that's
exactly what they were doing these
cultures all over the world transferring
into art so you may have got the hint
from me now that I believe that art and
music should be at the heart of our
school curriculums not the peripheries
and should serve the whole curriculum
and my teaching was all physics maths
nighti so it's not that I'm promoting my
own subjects I'm promoting something
that I wish I'd known earlier well so
the Greeks did us the favor of you know
handing down this knowledge to us but a
lot of your work has been advocating the
idea or discovering the idea and then
exploring it that many many other
cultures did this as well so tell us
about how you began to think that a lot
of things that archaeologists thought of
as you know monuments or works of art
and so forth really had this functional
purpose of helping primitive societies
to remember things I don't know if you
know about obsessions but when you're
obsessed with something your brain won't
think anything else I had no interest in
archaeology but my husband Damian had
was really into archaeology and a just
created not finished in archaeology
degree is third or fourth degree likes
collecting them and we went to England I
was researching indigenous animal
stories he wanted to go to Stonehenge so
I traced along and I'm standing there
looking at this circle of stones in
people's minds when I say Stonehenge
they'll think of those great big sarsens
the huge ones but they didn't come for
500 years
at first Stonehenge was a circle of
stones of about 60-something
stones a hundred meter across circle you
happy with meters
I can't computers are good yes I demand
that my listeners be able to use meters
that's okay
and there's a thousand circles big and
small of this all over Western Europe
but you've also got different versions
in America the the circles at Cahokia
wooden circles but they're the same
dimensions at Poverty Point in Louisiana
there's timber circles because there
were big stones so it's not the material
that matters it's these set of locations
so as I go to Stonehenge I'm thinking oh
that's clever of them they're no longer
moving around the landscape and the the
people moving around the landscape
hunting and gathering and doing some
Land Management that were not nomadic
they were mobile they moved from
location to location and knew their
landscape well so we're not talking
nomads we're talking mode sorry what is
the difference between a nomad and a
mobile culture nomads wander all over
the place uh-huh not systematically
mobile cultures move so our Aboriginal
cultures depending on where they are
might move between two or three
campsites or even only one over the year
down south but a lot more depending on
resources so they know there may be a
trajectory seasonal they know that
landscape really will if they're going
to settle for farming you can't just say
okay I'll settle today and start farming
you're gonna starve very quickly so
there's evidence in the archaeology
which I can waffle on for hours on how
they gradually move down but these
circles are stones
own and circles of timber and that all
over the world only appear in that
transition time so it's Stonehenge
there's the curses beforehand like the
Stonehenge curses see you are s us which
is a huge area that they ceremonial area
and it gradually got smaller until you
get Stonehenge which with these circle
of stones so if you think of that as a
memory palace nothing is going to work
better because stones and they bought
blue stones over from Wales and it looks
like it was actually Welsh cultures but
the blue stones are
very mottled than that and you know if
you look at a stone or a cloud or
anything you will see whatever you want
to see that hmm so and they they were
all different so they were actually
setting up a memory palace and so I that
was what my brain said so no so started
before you thought had that thought is
I'm not a stonehenge expert my
impression is that people have the idea
that it was some sort of astronomical or
crop planting device and you're you
really have a totally different theory
of why it was put there what you're
saying is absolutely true but my theory
encompasses all this because they must
have some way of timekeeping if you're
going to plant crops you must know where
you are in the season if you're going to
hunt and resources and they must have
still been collecting wild resources
while they develop these agricultural
skills so timekeeping is essential and
we know the indigenous abilities to use
the sky sky and variety astronomy over
the year for timekeeping the american
webelo people are really top-notch
astronomers and westerns astronomy is
learning a lot from them our Australian
Aboriginal cultures have a very strong
tradition of astronomy so I that's one
of the ten points I look at at any of
these monuments of whether it would be
used as a knowledge centre the spiritual
stuff's all there - I'm not denying that
but you're not going to be able to be
spiritual if you're not eating so those
ideas of the practical knowledge which
is my field is all there here you've got
a memory palace aligned to allow you
time keeping with ditches around it with
flat bottoms now nobody before has
explained why is the bottom of these
ditches flat so the ditch around
Stonehenge is a varies it different bits
around it but about two meters deep now
the weather in England is
Halling and we know that the major
ceremonies were held midwinter and
there's a whole lot of evidence for that
and if these ceremonies the imperative
is to perform them or you lose that
information to me to deep syrup in choc
with a flat bottom you can cover that
with and there's evidence of how they
did they cover that with hides and so on
and ensure that you perform that
ceremony in white chalk the resonance
would be beautiful the reflections of
the torches and a flat bottom allows you
to perform it with if you look at the
associated Stonehenge didn't stand alone
so let's start with Stonehenge with its
circle of stones and about 500 years in
they that circles moved into the center
and the great big sarsens that we're
more familiar with the huge stones with
the lentils on the top are put around
them now indigenous cultures all have a
lot of secrecy and restricted knowledge
the reason they have restricted
knowledge is that otherwise you've got
the Chinese whispers effect and the
knowledge will be ruined but lost
corrupted now we've got the stories here
as I've mentioned from 10,000 years ago
that are held accurately you've got the
same from Native American and Africa and
a lot of my work comes from Africa - on
these accuracy you must have secrecy in
order to only the people who are trained
in the songs that store the information
can actually have to be tested
constantly and they will not show if you
were just if you're just casually
knowledgeable about these particular
memories you might distort them a little
bit and you know it would get degrading
over time entropy the second law of
thermodynamics will kick in as which
we're both familiar with and so what
you're saying is that there's a
technique by restricting the knowledge
to those who are really dedicated to it
you could maintain its purity in some
way and keep it as you said over
thousands of years which for a
pre-written
culture is pretty impressive Donna she
one of the best studies I looked at was
of the corn stories of the Pueblo people
now there they have about 17 sub
varieties of corn and done in different
colors so the corn maidens and the corn
mothers are the different colors of the
corn their corn cross pollinates like
you wouldn't believe they have kept
these pure for we know for centuries
probably a lot longer by having all
these ceremonies and restricted so that
the yellow corn is planted at a
particular time from the white corn from
the other corn kept at a given distance
and then to eat the ceremonies that
people in the elders in charge of the
corn will select the very purest kernels
to be kept because if you have a
monoculture in you know the southwest of
the United States is a harsh climate say
you put all the yellow corn a nice sweet
one in and you had a season that was
really bad for yellow corn you just
wiped out your whole population so they
had this whole set of clever use of corn
that ensured maintenance of a culture
it's brilliant so you could remember
things that the culture the tribe or
whatever could remember things events
and how to deal with them even if those
events had not happened in the memory of
any living person and therefore it's put
into ritual and strong and rules and
ethics and behavior of the culture that
absolutely enshrines
dis potatoes methods and keeps their
corn pure it's just brilliant stuff and
so they didn't have books or they didn't
maybe even have epic poems I'm not quite
sure what they had but you're saying
that at a place like Stonehenge the
elders or I don't know they would go on
regular intervals and do these rituals
and then that would do Amit preps there
teaching there there that will be taken
to this also and so that you it you can
imagine that there is this association
of song and move
with the different parts of the memory
palace to keep this cultural knowledge
being transmitted safely and you would
perform those rituals at the appropriate
time in the year so there's one part of
Stonehenge where in the ditch there's
piglet skeletons nine-month-old piglet
skeletons and we know from all the
agriculture that that's mid winter which
was when they had the main ceremonies
now piglet skeleton was buried and then
hundreds of years later another one was
put into the wall of the the ditch so
that that would have been the time where
all the husbandry of Peaks and possibly
other animals was taught and so those
skeletons would have been used as part
of the ritual but part of teaching but
then it gets amazing once you've got
these big Saracens in I had a problem
then because one of my conditions is
there must be public performance spaces
and restrictive performance spaces and
Stonehenge became entirely restricted
but up the road at that exact time
exactly logically you know within years
though we're not talking a long time
Darington walls was built and this is
walking distance up the road this
massive henge and the ditches weren't 2
meters deep they were 10 meters deep and
they don't have any tools other than
deer stone tools or deer antlers red
deer antler and the ditch goes for a
kilometer you're talking a million work
hours and up till now people have not
had a reason why they would do this now
indigenous people do not do things for
no practical reason they're incredibly
practical so if that's the performance
sight can you imagine the acoustics and
vision of it it's like a a bathroom 10
meters deep the resonance and acoustics
and visually I want a hinge ditch I
desperately want when I nagged my
husband he refuses to dig me one but it
must have been extraordinary and then
you've got posts circles you've got all
and held Hill devices because that's the
other thing and does it matter does it
matter the
but the particular shapes of the stones
that forms don't hedge or anything like
that are or as long as all the stones
are different you could imagine
associating them with different than the
difference that matters so if you look
at ivory which is the biggest of these
stone ones in in England which which
also has the massive ditch in that the
archaeologists note how they seem to all
they called the male and female but that
the stones next to each other are as
different as you will get but I also
took the fact that these handheld
devices the African lacasa
Aboriginal chinga I started to put these
together and found them in every culture
so my logic said therefore they must be
in the British Neolithic as well and yes
there's chalk plaques
they're called enigmatic decorated
objects so Jacque plucks a little lumps
hand he'll not that little of chalk with
inscription you know decorated abstract
decorations work better because you can
add more meaning to it up north in
Scotland there's carved stone balls so
these are stone balls the right size to
be held in the hand with knobs and
carvings and things on them and nobody
had a theory for them I showed a picture
of the most elaborate one the tower ball
to an Aboriginal elder and he said oh
they've done that your ignorance isn't
that good now let me tell you here's one
of the great mysteries of the world no
one has been asking indigenous people
what these objects might be used for
American archaeologists do but in the
British New York Neil British they don't
have indigenous cultures hanging around
to chat with yeah yeah and it does seem
to be from what you've said what you've
implied pretty Universal that you know
is a there's a somehow a natural thing
for people and societies to do building
these kinds of monuments as this
combination of big monuments with small
hand held things to pass down knowledge
from generation to generation
it's you'll find that all over the world
in that transitional stage early
agriculture as soon as you get a big
society really big your skillset your
knowledge elders your professors start
to get specialists so okay knowledge is
then shared between them so in order to
hold power you then need to claim some
connection to the supernatural that
ordinary people don't have and you start
to get a priest class emerging which you
won't find in indigenous cultures so
they don't talk about worshiping these
ancestors and Kachina the pueblos
Kachina and so on they talk about
learning from them the stories they tell
they're much they're really like the
Greek gods gone back a bit more they
have much more depth and character and
flaws and everything that we can learn
from so you then I see Santo and the
monuments all just disappear Stonehenge
wasn't knocked down or anything it just
stopped being used the same with the the
big circles of Poverty Point Louisiana
and the big mounds mounds used a lot in
places that don't have big stones I had
a wonderful podcast with Mark de
villiers on the origin of the idea of
Hell and he was partly having fun
because hell is a fun topic to talk
about but you're suggesting something
pretty dramatic if I'm not over
interpreting it so let me restate it and
you can tell me if I'm on the right
track back in the day when it was
important to remember things for a very
very long time but we didn't have
writing or anything like that we
constructed these tools memory palaces
and hand held artifacts to help us
remember things and we would attribute
this knowledge to our ancestors since
they came up with it and we would pass
it down for many generations but then
over time as our society gets bigger we
begin to mythologize those ancestors and
even supernatural eyes then like before
was just yeah our ancestors told us this
they were really good thank you and then
it becomes we're almost worshiping our
ancestors and maybe this is the origin
of religion in some broad sense is that
okay I have thought that way and there's
others who before I haven't used that in
my
to research and my books because that's
adding a level of controversy and at
this stage I don't want to do that
because that's why podcasts are yeah and
I think that's definitely there's plenty
of evidence for that there's actually
examples from Native American and from
Maori the Maori can trace everything
back 800 years they did things a little
bit differently from everyone else I'll
get back to that in a moment the New
Zealand Maori this is a universal thing
and I think that you can trace religion
back that way and you can see in
particular in the Greek and Roman myths
where they associate things with
landscape the gods all live on
particular mountains and things but they
gradually start to worship them that
this change there and I think you'll
find it's to do with power my PhD thesis
is titled where knowledge was power
unfortunately these days I think
violence and and religion and money is
power but we won't get into politics
just this moment so the merry most
cultures use the landscape and then add
in complex genealogies and this is an
area that has been too complex for me to
replicate I've made sure replicate most
of the others but our Australian
Aboriginal cultures will relate every
single person in their culture and
everyone that comes in from associated
cultures into a complex genealogy map
Maori do it the reverse they use the
genealogies as the basic indexing system
and this is what Google if it's not
indexed on the internet you won't find
it all these systems are indexing
systems knowledge systems with a
complete link anything that's not linked
to a stones gonna get lost
so the marry you I can see you're
computer science background peeking
through here Information Technology
Theory Stonehenge a database structure
with the data all stored in memory it
just happened to be human memory that
died so that's really what it is and I
do have an information technology
background so that's the way look if you
don't have
formation indexed you loser you must sow
the merry index on genealogies they can
go back 800 generations
so when you look at the mythology there
are examples from the Pueblo and the
Navajo and from Maori of how those are
living ancestors go back far enough they
become mythological so the question are
the ancestors biological or mythological
is a question that can't be answered
that's a Western question because it
isn't a significance to the indigenous
cultures because they're both so we've
got stories of the Pueblo adding in a
Kachina a priest the priest killing
Katrina who wanders around with a priest
head telling the story of the Pueblo
Revolt and when they beat the Spanish
trying to take over their lands pueblos
are still on their own lands that's why
there's such a valuable culture and
their knowledge is so important so they
will add in stories they will add in
characters with time they may become
mythological it's the division that
doesn't matter so I've got Donald Trump
sitting here for America for me but he
will become mythological it's not the
real Donald Trump so it's a technique
yeah it's part of the story I mean we in
post European cultures and European
cultures and the ones we're descended
from we always lament the loss of the
Great Library at Alexandria but what
you're saying implies that you know a
lot of these European explorers and
conquerors as they wiped out these
artifacts from primitive civilizations
were destroying libraries in a very real
sense in Australia if you use the term
primitive referring to Aboriginal
cultures you would be in big big trouble
so we'll use non literate oh yeah I want
to do it right so so what I'm trying to
say is these were extremely intelligent
they had the same human brain and still
have yes we have but they stored
information differently so when if we're
talking Australia to her
years ago the British came here and took
land they were doing exactly that
burning down the encyclopedias
so the cruelty our physical cruelty to
Aboriginal people in the massacres and
so on was horrific the intellectual
cruelty was just as horrific they would
put fences across these song lines and
shoot anyone who came in because it was
agricultural land now so we know from
the yanyu of people right up australia
north but there's very few elders left
now so you know this is knowledge that's
very hard to get but they have 800
kilometers of song lines mapped out an
elder can sing 800 kilometres of
locations can navigate them and can
associate all that information with it
see a little bit more about what a song
line is in particular as a particular
text song line is a memory palace in the
bush so but it's sung because song is
more memorable so there's some knowledge
tracks and Native American sing and
dance because these are more memorable
events so they will sing these tracks
through the bush now people who come to
Australia and decide to go out hiking in
the bush can get lost and died 10 meters
from a path because our bush is very
dense and any bush you've got proper
wilderness there in England it's a bit
harder because they don't have any
proper wilderness live but to navigate
800 kilometers and this navigation paths
right across the whole of Australia
we're talking 10,000 kilometres ya know
1,000 let's not get ridiculous that
you've got these navigation tracks that
go all over Australia sound from memory
so they can teach somebody else to sing
the track and navigate from a song so
that's why they own some lines yeah I
mean it makes me wonder like what are
the kinds of things that were being
remembered this way clearly maps and
locations and probably plants and
animals are obvious ones you know what
other kinds of knowledge were there more
social kinds of knowledge like customs
and laws
were passed absolutely but you've also
got a lot of other things like water
holes in Australia the driest continent
on the earth they go right across the
desert so you want to know where the
water holes are how to find the best
Flint for napping and so on but there's
also all the cultural there is a huge
base of ethical laws and I have read so
often that philosophy and ethics and
everything started with the Greeks and
started with literacy that is highly
offensive to indigenous cultures because
they have very detailed ethical cultural
responsibilities which keep them going
I mean without them so you've got the
stories you talked about some of the
scary stuff that Bunyip stories here and
they're scary that stops children
wandering from the camp
you can't fence them but if you've got
stories of the bunyip out there they're
not gonna leave mum and dad so a bit
although there are all these other
aspects to it being a scientist I focus
on the absolute pragmatic and this so
much of that I haven't run out of stuff
to research well you had this wonderful
example that I saw of the loon of the
red-billed loon maybe that helped
sailors or helped people out on the
ocean find their way back okay so the
red-throated loon or rhoda loon is
closed some cultures call it the diver
but the Native American up on the
northwest of just checking my geography
northwest coast in Canada have these
loon and they have totem poles including
the Loon Pole now the loon is a
particularly interesting bird it's not
particularly interesting to look at it's
a it's not a pelagic bird now pelagic
birds of water birds that will go out
like albatrosses and so on and stay out
at sea forever
the Loon will always come back to land
at night so if you do your hunting magic
and I hate that term because it implies
it's non non rational when they before
the the cultures that used the lunar and
it's used right across the north of the
world they will sing the call of the
before they go out and say that that
saves lives because it does if there's a
storm comes in and all the water birds
will be making a racket if you can pick
out the Loon call and follow that exact
call you will get back to land it might
be where you want to get but you will
get back to land and be saved and it
calls the red-throated learn in
particular there's other loons that
aren't quite as good so you if possible
get the red-throated because it will not
stop calling the whole way back
so before say Aboriginal people go out
hunting they will dance the behavior of
the animal they're hunting like a
kangaroo
because without guns you have to get
fairly close and you don't want to alert
it and you don't want to yell at hey
Fred the Roos over there so they have
all sorts of communication systems which
they dance before they go out in the
hunt to get their strategies ready and
their survival techniques ready
it's incredible stuff this is the kind
of knowledge the sort of local knowledge
that you absolutely need that that you
can imagine should be passed down from
generation to generation you can't just
take you get it and then let it go and
think they're gonna remember it when
they need it thirty years later so it
seems perfectly reasonable to me that
structures like Stonehenge were used to
keep information there were libraries of
a sort but presumably I'm gonna guess
there are people who don't agree I mean
how do we know or at least how do we
judge whether that was it is it a sort
of consistency check is it a matter of
being able to fit other pieces of data
into the picture that makes us go yeah
this is probably on the right track I
haven't had anyone who doesn't agree
some people think I overstate it which I
probably do because there will be all
the other aspects and indigenous
ceremonies do have all the spiritual and
that which I tend to say yes they do and
then ignore it so I am overstating that
so I'm saying this is their primary
purpose not their entire purpose it's
the consistency I've got a set of ten in
my Cambridge University Press book and
PhD thesis a set of
in tests and if I don't get nine out of
ten it goes that just because some don't
have cave art and some don't you know
then but that there must be acoustics
astronomical alignments a set of system
if I find and I've got tests for
dismissing it if you can find a single
set of standing stones in the British
Neolithic do not follow a pattern that
you can easily navigate because it must
be a sequence a set of timber circles
anywhere in there used in Europe but
also right across the Americas that
can't be navigated in sequence the
sequence isn't obvious the theory falls
apart but there has never happened yet
so what I want is all these different
indicators to be in place and that
consistency is everywhere and it's only
in early agricultural non literate
cultures so it is a set as consistency
and that same consistency with non
literate cultures all over the world so
I've worked with linguists at one of the
scariest seminars I ever gave was with a
group of linguists specializing in
recording the languages of these
cultures and if any of these cultures
did not follow these same patterns all
over the world the theory would fall
apart and not one person that room would
argue but then when you look at the
neuroscience we're just matching the
human brain I mean in evolutionary terms
I'm talking probably only 10,000 years I
mean Stonehenge is a mere five thousand
years that's just a baby so know if I
find an easy then I'll worry do you know
about the extended cognition thesis have
you heard those words a little bit but
you know there's embodied cognition
which which claims that when we when we
do cognition when we do the sort of
higher-level abstract thinking it's not
just in our brains it's in the rest of
our bodies as well extended cognition
says we should include our notebooks and
our tools in our environment in
literally the raw materials of how we
think and you know spiders offload
pieces of knowledge into the designs of
their spider webs and so sort and and so
forth and so this is a form of that
right like really these things that we
do to the environment whether it's a
handheld artifact that we make or a
large-scale monument this is part of our
thinking capacity yes I wasn't sure
whether you were going into the New Age
collective consciousness type thing oh
no I was not no that's why I was
hesitant absolutely there's research and
education that a child with a computer
is in fact more intelligent because
they've got more knowledge available to
them so yes absolutely except that if
you rely on it entirely a computer or
some way of offloading your memories you
haven't got something to play with
information so this higher levels of
Bloom's taxonomy and that that goes up
into creativity and theorizing I
couldn't imagine that I could do so much
of that until I had this base of
knowledge in there to play with so for
education I'm advocating we bring these
methods back but I'm not advocating
changing the curriculum because if you
put them as our creating arts so for
mathematical tables which people need to
know instantly not calculate up to them
because when I see kids doing now if
they want 6/8 they calculate up through
you know I know two eighths rates for it
if you create an image with a story and
we're using in the schools that I'm
working with we use we're calling them
rapscallions because we can't call them
Katrina
these characters and take the pueblos or
ancestors only because that would be
culturally most inappropriate we decide
to call them chi-chi's to give them
character until we googled it and got a
lot of bottoms so we went over two
rapscallions so say for a tables for 6/8
48 you wanted instant image so all sixes
are sticks all eights agates all fours
for TS a naughty so the kids
have their own rapscallion and that
gives it an emotional attachment they
have to create an image of sticks and
gates naughty gate so the rapscallion
picks up skip six liens on a gate and
the gate locks and flying something like
that which they paint that time
commitment to the single table makes
them bring it back instantly and you
don't need to do the whole six eight and
eight sixes are the same so that's got
rid of behalf them tens 11s and ones you
don't need to do because the patterns so
that commitment in time will get every
table instant so you're saying that see
that there are implications for early
education but like you said not changing
the curriculum but introducing some new
techniques and again it takes us back to
the point that it's not just a parlor
trick to memorize things it helps if
done correctly presumably it helps
solidify the foundation of the kinds of
knowledge that we have yeah I take out
the early education donorsearch with
senior secondary so a periodic table is
the obvious one
you Wacka did a memory palace every
fifth location the Greek ancient Greeks
said make every fifth location sequence
so they can get the number the atomic
number easily every noble gas they would
bow to so when the kids come up to
number 10
neon is a door because it's a tenth they
need it and then they bowed and
apologized because it's noble gas killed
themselves laughing neon noble gas
number ten is in and from that because
they've got it as a noble gas they can
go forward and backwards and get its
position and it's behaviours they sing
the lanthanides lalalala lanthanides
they act out the actinides which gets
very explosive because they're all
radioactive pro actinium they keep
thinking as a prostitute I wish they
wouldn't have that in it gets very
interesting but so that sort of thing
for seniors we've done it with art stuff
you've got an American world
memory champion there Alex Mullen mu
llen he is he and Kathy Chen his partner
a medical students and their website
Mullen memory shows how they're using
all these techniques in studying
medicine University and so on so this is
everywhere and it's right through life
because how much of dementia not that
there's a whole lot of dementia how much
of dementia is that we stop laying down
memories and identity so instead of
singing I love you I love you I've lost
you I can't live without you which we
tend to sing non-stop why aren't we
singing knowledge as indigenous cultures
do and that music is one of the last
things to go why aren't we creating
devices that are a sequence of our life
so that there is our identity and we've
been doing this with some people here
and you know how kids object to granny
I've heard that teen time that story up
ten times if you've got on a memory
device and they point to it the kids
want to tell you the story and you're
creating an heirloom and we're the ones
we're using here in workshops here are
based on the Native American winter
counts of the Lakota people where they
did history done on hides they work
wonderfully so it's early education yep
and let's keep it going right through
life and okay so for someone like me you
know I'm a physics professor I've not
really used these techniques very well I
think that I think that I remember in
one of the things I read about you you
claiming that before you learned these
techniques you're you were not very good
at memory right it was really this
falling like bad appallingly bad is so
so I'll give you the chance to make the
sales pitch like if there's one thing
one thing that would help convince me
that this is a set of techniques that I
could should study going further is
there something particular I should try
to either learn or help myself with or
you know just give a whirl - I think
grounding the definitions is really
important so I did a physics experiment
with a whole group of kids that force
was the
the topic that they would to do all of
them from and then we're talking
five-year-olds up to 12 year olds
because of the way rural schools work
here and the curriculum so they did all
the experiments with balloons going
everywhere and so on at the end I
quizzed all seventy students said do you
remember doing force in science yes what
is a force 3 out of 17 told me it was a
push or pull lots told me it's what when
parents make you do things you don't
want some told me it's what makes the
balloon go across the room and half of
them said may the force be with you and
as a physicist you will know that is not
good physics we hope it's not the first
answer they give yeah that's this one
right which means as those teachers are
going on you saying force this force it
those kids are not basing any of that
information on form foundation so the
music teacher took the Imperial March
from Star Wars and created a little song
saying of forces to put your pull push a
ball I can't do it without the actions
as you can see I know no questions the
kids sang it in music and an assembly
they're not mentioned for a week 70 kids
the same wording of the questions you
remember doing force in science 70 out
of 70 told me it was a push or a pull
did the actions and started laughing
therefore I'm not saying we sing
everything we sing Li or dance or
perform or memory palace the absolute
things we need grounded we must know
what a forces or else everything we do
from then on it's based on sand well
it's a good message there's still a room
for the human mind and brain and memory
recollection possibilities even a world
where we can all type questions into
Wikipedia or Google very very quickly
absolutely and be fun they really are
and they're fun that's the best part
okay Lynne Kelly thanks so much for
being on the podcast it's an absolute
pleasure Sean
[Music]